so hello and welcome to another episode
of biographics I'm your host Cal
Smallwood and today we're talking about
something specifically for the spooky
season specifically the fox sisters the
frauds who helped found spiritualism I
should mention like all of our videos
this one is based on original article
submitted by a member of our team of
handsome well-endowed writers this one
being Larry holsworth you can find links
to their socials below let's get to
it
spiritualism a belief in an afterlife
where the spirits of the Dead retain
some conscious awareness of like know
the world around them and can
communicate with the living began to
take hold in Britain and the United
States in the mid to late 19th century
the belief in a life after death
included the acceptance that Spirits
were more ethically and morally advanced
in the living could therefore provide
moral guidance to us still shuffling
along with moral coil as a result a new
type of Fortune tell emerged the medium
one who possessed the ability to
communicate with the spirits of the de
medium served as a bridge of sorts
between the living and the dead using
several different means of exchanging
messages most of them confusing and most
of them conveniently very easily faked
the means of communication evolved over
the years in the beginning communication
consisted mainly of small wrapping
noises think like you know fingers
wrapping on a desk or small cracking
noises however would you fake that the
medium questioned the spirit asking it
to reply with a specific number of wraps
later communication though included
Spirit writing moans and shrieks Moon
objects about our room drafts and so on
and so forth spiritualism Roots can be
traced to Upstate New York where it
emerged during a period of religious
revival in the 1840s among its earliest
proponents were three sisters who hailed
from H highville near Rochester and the
shores of Lake Erie near the genese
river like it's quite conv they were
born near Lake Erie and they could
communicate with ghosts that's very it's
very fitting Leia Margaretta Pence for
referred to as mag as name she went by
and Catherine Fox were raised in the
Methodist Faith the sisters had been
born in on Ontario before relocating to
he highville in 1847 Leia the eldest of
the three was born in 1813 Magie was 20
years younger born in 1833 while
Katherine who preferred to be called
Kate was born in 1837 in 1848 the
younger two sisters began to claim their
he highville home was haunted reporting
mysterious sounds at night including
inexplicable rapping noises concerned
their parents sent the sisters to
relatives and acquaintances in Rochester
the girls reported the rapping sounds
followed them to their new homes when a
prominent Quaker family learned of the
strange reports of the sisters they
spread the word to their weekly meetings
through the Quakers the spiritualist
movement began and grew rapidly the
sisters became local and later
International celebrities who remain
leading figures in spiritualism well
into the 21st century as the
spiritualist movement grew an argument
began over whether it was like you
know kind of bad to like know taunt
ghosts proponents argued that if one
believed in angels devils and the
afterlife all part of the Christian
dogma one must necessarily believe
believe in the existence of the immortal
Soul therefore communication with that
Immortal Soul was not in any way immoral
you just you just talk into something
that you all believe exist it's not
witchcraft or heresy right but why some
possess disability and others did not
was the matter of some debate and later
arguments against spiritualism were
based largely on science rather than
Biblical verses but that's besides the
point and we're getting far ahead of
ourselves whether Some Humans Do
actually possess the ability to
communicate with the dead is an argument
which still rages and count medium still
practice it today will Michael answer a
question yes he would like he would like
this the strange rappings that the
sisters reported they had heard in their
he highville home took on a more
Sinister Aura when rumors began to
circulate there had been a murder on the
property some years before H prominent
citizens of Rochester searched the home
and nearby barn and though they did not
uncover any clear evidence of a murder
that is any evidence whatsoever the
rumor was just too good to fade
supposedly a traveling pedler had been
killed explaining why there had been no
reports of a missing person at the time
the story also provided a convenient
means of explaining why an upset Spirit
occupied the home itself in addition the
area surrounding Rochester had long been
one where religious activity abounded to
the point it had gained the name of the
burned El District Mormonism had emerged
in the area in the 1820s and what
eventually became seventh day adventism
began in the region and extension of the
teachings of William Miller who had
prophesies the second coming of Jesus
Christ which would occur in the mid to
early 1840s so 200 years out almost
still time go on fingers crossed come on
the region had been a hot bed of the
Shaker sect and was home to utopian
experiments Revival meetings and other
similar activities and now ghosts who
could communicate by doing
this when words spread around Rochester
and its environs that the strange
wrapping sounds reported in the fox's he
highville home had evidently followed
the sisters to Rochester where both
report continuing to hear them despite
living in separate residences public
interest grew the sisters gained the
reputation of being able to communicate
with the dead thus giving proof of an
afterlife and a link to the Eternal
knowledge contained therein in Rochester
a guy called Isaac post and his wife Amy
contact the sisters through Leia who by
then had also claimed to possess the
same extraordinary power as her younger
sisters both posts were considered
dangerous radicals by the more
conservative citizens of Rochester so
what could they have possibly done be
considered so radical you pasal Isaac
was a leader of a breakaway sect of the
Society of Friends known as the hick
sites who was also a leading
abolitionist a conductor of the
Underground Railroad and a supporter of
the formerly enslaved Frederick Douglas
Post actually helped Douglas establish
his newspaper the North Star as for his
wife she was considered even more
radical than her husband because in
addition to supporting the rights of
black people she also supported women's
suffrage that's what was considered
radical at the time just you know put
into perspective the era we're talking
about here the post invited the foxes to
to demonstrate their abilities in their
home in a seance attended by several of
their influential friends Isaac post lat
recounted that they had entered the
meeting as a doubter writing and I quote
I suppose I went with as much unbelief
as Thomas felt when he was introduced to
Jesus after he had ascended the girls
however managed to convince him that
they could indeed communicate with the
dead as they did for nearly all the
witnesses present during that first
faithful Seance later Leia convinced the
post that she had received
Communications from their recently
deceased daughter Isaac rented the newly
buil Corinthian Hall in Rochester 400
tickets were sold for a demonstration of
the sister's remarkable abilities which
took place on November 14th 1849
Skeptics were invited to attend and to
examine the girls following the
demonstration to determine whether any
trickery whatsoever was involved and
those several Skeptics did attend and
the girls were examined quite thoroughly
following the demonstration no evidence
of trickery was found
[Music]
H Andrew Jackson Davis was a likely
educated a charlatan who believed he
possessed the ability to diagnose and
cure illness through magnetism which is
now known as hypnotism although both
would be equally as likely he also
claimed to be a clairvoyant in 1845 he
dictated a book to an assistant while in
a trance he believed that while he was
in this trance he received the very
secrets of nature itself and in 1847
published those findings in a book
titled the principles of nature her
Divine Revelations and a voice to
mankind so one critic Savaged the book
stating it was a very crude and badly
digested mess of early scientific
literature why am I so bad at
pronouncing literature he subsequently
published several more works with
equally for boing titles and once claim
we've been shown what he called
Summerland he describes Summerland as
the place where Souls reside after death
it's like no man Valla for this dude you
know I was brought into this world
screaming covered in blood that's the
way I'm going to leave it and and that's
a joke and a reference to The Simpsons
so Davis had heard of the sister's
success in Rochester and invited them to
visit him at his home in New York Davis
was one of the early proponents of the
growing belief in spiritualism and
forsaw that linking his work to theirs
would like you know Advance this cause
as well as you know make them lots and
lots of money you got to get that Dutch
vandelier on and make that money so ler
Kate and Maggie traveled to New York
established themselves in baram's hotel
and Hell schedule seances three times a
day every day in the Parlor there were
of course Skeptics including Scientific
American which derided them as frauds
yet many influential nework Yorkers and
visitors to the city attended the
sessions observing their Communications
of the Dead for the price of $1 as many
as 30 people could attend each session
and the sisters graciously arranged for
private sittings when desired for a
price after their success in New York
which was duly reported in the
newspapers and magazines Kate and Maggie
departed taking their show on the road
they traveled the major Eastern cities
going as far west as St Louis and to the
nation's capital then known as
Washington City in Washington Maggie was
approached by Jane Pi the wife of
Franklin Pierce their son Benjamin had
died in a train wreck as they journeyed
to Washington for Franklin's
inauguration as the President of the
United States the Sals was held
privately and its results are also
private so we don't actually know what
went on but it's interesting nonetheless
by 1852 Maggie and Kate were in
Philadelphia where they met Elisha Kent
Kaine Kane was nearly as famous as the
fox sisters but for shall we say
entirely different reasons as the
sisters performed their seances and
helped spread belief in spiritualism
Kane served as the United States Naval
Medical officer and accompanied several
expeditions to the Arctic he was a Fame
public speaker giving lectures on Arctic
exploration navigation medicine and
nutrition he was a man of science and of
Common Sense he was absolutely convinced
that the fox sisters were frauds he was
also convinced that one of the fox
sisters was a fox so when he failed to
uncover any evidence of how they
generate the strange wrapping noises
which was featuring their performances
he decided that he was just going to try
to sleep with one of them specifically
the sister he was after was Maggie who
was at the time 19 years of age e some
accounts including Maggie's own claim
that they were married in 1856 after
which she renounced spiritualism and
eventually converted to Catholicism Cain
was a presbyterian following his death
in 1857 Maggie initiated lawsuits with
his family over his estate the
settlements of which remained murky
although she claimed to have renounced
spiritualism she eventually returned to
it and renewed her claim that she could
indeed communicate with the dead at
which point surely the the court case
against like her deceased former husband
would be really easy to prove because
you could just ask
him in 1866 Maggie published a book
titled the love life of Dr Kane it
contained copies of the correspondence
fre Maggie and the noted Explorer
including references to their secret
marriage he also contain a history of
their relationship written by an
unidentified writer Maggie's letters
appear in the book as do those of Elisha
Kain but she was not identified as the
writer of the text itself although I
come on during her sister's romantic
interlude Kate continued to enhance and
develop her spiritual and psychic powers
by the early 1870s she was no longer
dependent solely on coded rapping in her
Communications she demonstrated the
ability to receive messages through
Spirit writing while simultaneously
receiving another which she would repeat
verbally unsurprisingly in the aftermath
of the Civil War grieving families and
Widow sought Solace and her business
boomed yeah so I was going to make a
joke about like you know powering up
like she was in like the 1870s version
of cerebro but then you just get crashed
back down to Earth by the fact she was
exploiting the grief of people whose
families had recently
died it's a predatory awful business the
Civil War was good for the spiritualist
movement in general as more and more
people abandoned more traditional faith
and sought to communicate with lost
loved ones Magie returned to
spiritualism during the war and both
sisters began to include wine in their
seces by the war's end both were
encountering problems with their
drinking in the gu a spiritualism boomed
the fox sisters were far from the only
practitioners of seanes and
Communications with the dead though they
were in some ways among the most
flamboyant Kate once claimed to have
conjured the spirit of Benjamin Franklin
himself who identified himself by
signing his name how could you fake that
other practitioners convinced their
followers of the validity of their
claims using the emerging technology of
photographs William mumler was one sort
spiritualist who was consulted by Mary
Todd Lincoln following the assassination
of her husband yes we're talking about
that l
so Muma produced a photograph in which
the image of the Dead president stands
behind his widow his hands resting
gently on her shoulder in case it wasn't
clear it was fake so the image was
reproduced in newspapers and in
magazines peing the interest of readers
in the practice it's worth noting that
spiritualism wasn't just limited to
America in Great Britain spiritualists
and Clairvoyant plied their trade with
many of the most famous Coming to
America to consult with their fellows
and you know make money one of the most
fervid Believers in spiritualism was
none other than bed British writer Sir
Arthur Conan Doyle the creator of
Sherlock Holmes and we've actually
talked about that in another biographics
video which will no doubt be linked on
screen or down below regardless Arthur
Conan Doyle's writings on the defense of
the Paranormal and its existence were
popular on both sides of the Atlantic
and just fun fact um Arthur con and Dole
like stop being friends with Harry
Houdini who is mentioned later in this
video as one of the people who debunked
spiritualism as a whole um because he
believed that har Houdini was a wizard
who used his wizard powers to suppress
the powers of other lesser
Wizards yeah and just Houdini got so
sick of like artha conand Dole saying
you're a wizard is like I'm not a wizard
I'm a magician like it's all fake it's a
TR like no you're a wizard using your
wizard powers like stop calling me a
wizard so the fox sisters were among the
first and by the Gilded Age the most
famous spiritualists in the world and
for over three decades they had
conducted sances and demonstrations of
their power and survived all the cause
of Fraud and deception which been
harried their way and by this point all
three had married and Maggie by then was
actually a widow with her claims
regarding K with true during an 1872
trip to London Kate married a barrister
named jenin providing her with two sons
Leia who by then was on her second
husband her first having died the
sisters then fell out with each other
leading to their downfall and just for a
moment let's just put like put yourself
in the boots of a guy he's like you know
you're approaching a girl and she's a
widow oh no that's that that sucks um
you want to go on a date and say yeah
yeah cool on that date she reveals that
she is a spiritualist in communicate
with the dead how much of a horn dog do
you have to be to continue pursuing that
relationship when the person you're
talking to has confirmed to you that
they can communicate with the dead it's
like surely the the the husband who
passed away is going to make that
awkward right surely surely you can't be
serious I am serious and don't call me
surely it began with Leia she had
throughout the sister's careers control
virtually everything about their lives
their appearances their schedules and
their Public Image from a lofty perch as
the eldest sister she had created the
frequently grinding schedules the
conversation with the writers and
newspapers and virtually all aspects of
their joint careers by the mid 1880s
Maggie and Kate were chafing under her
thumb and both had began drinking
heavily Kate's drinking in particular
was a concern and Leia Enlisted the
support of another leading spiritualist
in remonstrating her with her Wayward
sister Leia would later Express publicly
that Kate's excessive drinking was bad
for both her spiritualism and for her
two children not mentioned was you know
the money Kate and Maggie had always
been close with each other than their
much older sister who remember was like
know two decades their senior and Maggie
was particularly angry with what she
perceived as attacks on Kate without
layer's knowledge Maggie booked an
appearance in New York at the Academy of
Music for October 21st 1888 that day an
interview appeared in which Maggie
informed the New York World her
intention to announce that the sisters
entire four decade career of
spiritualists and mediums had been an
elaborate fraud the world paid her $150
$100 for a confession the modern
equivalent of just under
$50,000 sagi's interview in the New York
world ensured that her appearance at the
Academy of Music was well attended
spiritualists deniers debunkers and
reporters packed the hall tight Maggi
addressed the audience with a disarming
cander referring to their performances
and claims to receive messages from the
dead as and I quote a horrible deception
which begun in their highville home
years before as a simp prank she claimed
that the girls had first created a
rapping Sounds by I kid you not Folks at
home dragging an apple across the floor
with a string according to Maggie the
later rapping sounds that were heard in
many of their sances were made by their
Knuckles ankles toes and knees which
they cracked to produce the sounds and
friend out there who thinks that sounds
kind of unbelievable as someone who
possesses like creaky boneitis and can
like know crack a lot of their joints
and uh bones at will I will demonstrate
now what as a warning you can turn it
down person who's capable of doing this
but now imagine that in like a really
old creaky Hall and you're doing on a
wooden floor because that's what the
sisters will do she also pointed out
that during their seances individuals
eager for contact with lost loved ones
contributed to the illusion the rapping
sounds caused many to imagine or believe
they had felt physical contact a touch
on the arm the hand or on the shoulder
she would State it's a very common
delusion and one we saw a lot in
particular Maggie recalled a very early
Seance after which she generated a
wrapping sound her client said that she
felt the spirit tapping me on the
shoulder of course Maggie added that
that was Pure Imagination for all the
naysayers of her naysaying she did offer
to demonstrate this ability and
according to the report of the New York
Herald claimed that it was in this way
she created the excitement that has
driven so many persons to Suicide or
Insanity Maggie demonstrated her ability
to create rapping sounds using her toes
cracking them at will producing sounds
magnified by the room the trick she
would use is she would crack her like
toes ankles like know rolling her feet
and stuff on the hard wooden floor you
might think well surely you'd noticed
that right right you just notice if like
all they were doing is just cracking
their toes over and over again you have
to keep in mind folks that the dress of
the time was long flowing ones that you
know didn't reveal any of that sexy sexy
ankle allowing the um the sisters to
just hide what they were doing from
onlookers as for how she developed this
astonishing ability to crack her bones
at will according to Maggie her and Kate
just practiced it as children and she
also additionally claimed her older
sister was always aware of the deception
and has sought to abuse it for financial
gain perhaps the most withering thing
Maggie claimed though is that her
confession was pretty much the nail in
the coffin the idea of spiritualism
because it basically proved that the
entire thing was based on fraudulent
exploitation of the emotions of those
seeking contact with the dead she closed
her remarks with gratitude for finally
clearing her conscience and revealing
the deception while a lot of Skeptics
use Maggie's confession to proclaim the
end of spiritualism others were not so
sanguin leading spiritualists were not
about to let their Believers go away
read cash cows um disenchanted by what
Maggie had revealed they charged that
Maggi had been driven to attack
spiritualism for financial gain the
irony having lost much of her audience
of Believers following her conversion to
Catholicism others claimed that Maggie
and presumably her sisters were genuine
spiritualists and their contact with the
other side were legitimate they argued
that Maggie's more recent pronouncements
were caused by Spirits intent on harming
Humanity yeah this is what they did in
effect they argue that Maggie had been
seized by evil spirits the devil made
her do it it's like she can communicate
with the spirits but the spirits are
lying about her being able to
communicate with the spirits for reasons
so whatever her motive may have been
within the Year Maggie recanted her
entire confession and speech of October
21st she appeared to have waffle back
and forth for the next few years
claiming intermittently to have the
powers to receive messages from the dead
and appearing in Incognito at various
Gatherings of spiritualists to debunk
their methods of communication she was a
complicated person to say the least and
I'm guessing you know the alcohol had
something to do with that she remained
estranged from Leia and both sisters
lost track of Kate despite her recanting
and returning to spiritualism Maggie
failed to generate much interest in her
sances impoverished she wandered about
Brooklyn living on handouts Kate died in
1892 in New York City Maggie slipped
deeper into alcoholism and within a few
months was living in a tenement
supported solely by charity another
spiritualist Emily rugles took pity on
her and moved her into her home in
Brooklyn she died in March 1893 the once
celebrated Margaret Fox joins the
spirits in fact read her obituary
headline in the Philadelphia Inquirer
Leia had preceded her younger sisters in
death in 1890 yet to many spiritualists
the sisters did not die and they
remained a major influence on the
spiritualism movement as it continued to
expand well into the 20th century and
even to this
day
spiritualism continued to grow and
expand in the first half of the 20th
century and experienced a boom of sorts
following the global catastrophes of the
first world war and the Spanish Flu
pandemic In 1902 Frank podmore an
English physical researcher and skeptic
of spiritualism wrote an influential
book on the subject titled simply modern
spiritualism podmore related several
examples of the fox sisters
Communications with the dead as well as
Maggie description of the fraud they had
perpetrated yet he also stressed that
both Maggie and Kay had later recanted
the confession though podmore was a self
described skeptic regarding spiritual
Communications he was a believer in both
telepathic Communications and the
existence of ghosts he just didn't
believe that he could use one to
communicate with the other which is a a
very strange things to believe in tandem
but I guess people are complicated so
podmore postulated that ghost did
communicate with the living through
telepathic means including in dreams
they were just skeptical like the fox
sisters were able to do so in 1926 ARA
con and Doyle you know mentioned
previously published the history of
spiritualism he too recounted the story
of the fox sisters focusing on their
spiritual Communications with the dead
and ignored the accounts of fraud
completely including the ones admitted
by themselves so did you remember
earlier in this video where I talked
about the rumors of a peddler who died
on the property the sisters grew up on
after con and Di like recounted that
story in his book but failed to mention
the fact that nobody was found in fact
he noted that they found Bones on the
property he he failed to know those
bones belong to a chicken but bones they
probably also won't surprise you to
learn that Arthur con and do failed to
mention or discuss the many
investigations into the sisters during
their careers and the findings of
Skeptics which were eventually confirmed
by Maggie's own confession there are a
lot of these by the way so throughout
the sister's career Skeptics had
investigated their Communications with
several reporting that the strange
rapping noises were self-created by
means of cracking of the joints
according to these Skeptics the sisters
favored using their toes and ankles for
such noises since the long skirts of the
day concealed their movements in one
study the sisters were Seated on a a
sofa rather than the hard circular table
favored for their seances their feet
were placed on cushions around the wood
floors typical of most Seance seatings
when the sisters failed to produce any
rapping sounds they blame the failures
on the absence of Cooperative Spirits
despite all this support as of
spiritualism continued to expand upon
the numerous abilities and career of the
fox sisters for decades and still do to
the present day despite you
know the lie as the idea of
communicating with Spirits grew the fox
sisters became symbolic of it Beginnings
they often cited as the founders of
spiritualism itself an erronous
assertation though they were among its
earliest and best known practitioners
their position as Founders came from
none other than the fame Vilan Harry
Houdini so in 1925 The Illusionist and
scape artist Harry Houdini published an
article titled how I mask the spirit
fakers in his article Houdini mentioned
that subsequent mediums continue to
exploit the same tricks used by the fox
sisters to delude their subjects who
didn't refer to practicing spirit
mediums as vultures and that they were
and I quote most contempt and meanest
criminals that walk the earth he then
stated that and I quote once again the
fox sisters Margaret and Kate were the
founders of spiritualism as it is known
today Houdini described how the sisters
developed their skills creating rapping
sounds and added once again I'm quoting
here an older sister saw commercial
possibilities in the odd accomplishments
of the children and exploited them
widely he concluded and I quote one
final time that was the beginning of
spiritualism and as an aside here if
anyone curious about why Harry Houdini
had such a hard on for debunking
spiritualists um like many people he was
a Believer initially in the idea of
communicating with Spirits because you
know it was a prevalent thing at the
time and he was completely um sideswiped
and turned off the idea when he went to
see a medium following the death of his
mother and he asked the medium can you
you know communicate with my mother I'd
like to know if she's okay can you do
that for me and the medium's like say no
more went through the the usual while
I'm in contact with your mother now Mr
Houdini and Houdini obviously asked like
what did she say to which the
spiritualist replied she says Harry it's
okay which confused Houdini who asked
the
spiritualist why did she call me Harry
to which the spir the spiritualist
responded well that she name to which
houd responded no it's not my mother
doesn't call me Harry she also doesn't
speak English she's Hungarian and the
spiritualist just you know waffled on
for a few minutes and claimed that he
lost the connection and Houdini was so
disillusioned in that moment he just
decided then and there that all
spiritualists were charlatans and
thieves and for anyone who doesn't know
Harry Houdini was just his stage name he
was born Eric Weiss spiritualism is
still widely practiced today both by
independent mediums and those in
affiliations with groups such as the
National spiritualist Association of
churches in the United States in Great
Britain the spiritualist national Union
has been the dominant organization since
the 1890s medians continue to apply
their trade on television and on
podcasts and Via websites and in private
practice they also continue to attract
derision from some complete faith and
trust from others and shrugs from the
indifferent how one perceives them
depends to a large degree on what
perception one has over things I go bump
in the
night so thank you for watching this
video hopefully you found it interesting
I certainly found it interesting to
record um as mentioned this video was
based on original article submitted by a
member of our team of writers Larry
holsworth thank you to them I hope
everyone out there is enjoying their
spooky season hope you have a very nice
Halloween day and I'll be remiss if I
didn't share a spooky story of my own so
my tone throughout this video has been
you know quite dismissive of the idea of
communicating with ghosts but that's not
to say I'm a non-believer my mother for
example is a firm believer in the idea
of ghosts and spirits and communicating
with the dead and she swears on my own
life that the following story I'm about
to recount happened as I going to say it
so uh the reasons that I don't really
feel the need to get into my younger
sister was not expected to survive birth
but she did so anyway and uh shortly
prior to we being born my grandmother
passed and my grandmother had um spent
many many months on her deathbed like
you know just telling my mother it's
okay the baby's going to be okay the
baby's going to be okay I'll make sure
it's okay passed away few complications
I don't want to get into my mother's
privacy happened and my sister
miraculously survived them and was born
the day she gets brought back from the
hospital my mom walks through the
threshold of her home and all the lights
go absolutely ape [__] like they are
flashing they like the lights are
blinking on and off my electrical
devices are turning on and off my mom is
in hysterics um she turns to my sister's
dad my stepdad and says it's my mom I
know it's my mom she's here why why is
she here U my stepdad strolled into the
house and exclaimed at the top of his
voice Tammy my grandmother's name um you
know you're scaring your daughter Jamie
my sister is fine you don't need to be
here anymore you can go all the lights
turned off massive like you know like
all the fuses blue that was it and at
the same time that was happening the
lights were also flashing in my mother's
sister's house and her dad's house you
know the Widow of her mother and yeah um
that she claims to this day that was her
mother communicating with her to let her
know that she was okay and that my
sister was going to be fine and yeah I
would be remissed if I didn't tell that
story because you know it's spooky
season time for scary stories and if you
got your own scary story or encounter
with the occult the unknown or a spooky
ghost you know let us know in the
comments and like this video If you
enjoyed it subscribe if you want to see
more and as always have the day you
deserve